as as you may know that Junior doctors
and other doctors in in the BMA are also
looking for an improved pay deal from
this government it's a real great shame
that Therese coffee hasn't taken the
opportunity this morning to emphasize
the value of medical and nursing staff
to the Health Service and chosen to talk
to us we have written to Therese coffee
asking us asking for some discussions
about pay and we haven't had any
responses so it's it's unfortunate to
hear that but we are still open to talks
and and we wish the RCN all solidarity
okay do you feel that um doctors Junior
doctors might also find themselves in a
position where they have no alternative
but to consider strike action
unfortunately yes that's the case so the
junior doctors Committee of the BNA have
already said that if demands for
increased pay aren't met that there will
be a ballot in January so we're already
on our way there for both doctors and of
course for nurses okay talk to me about
the report that you have done with the
doctors Association what were you hoping
to achieve from that
so we've had a number of members come to
us a number of doctors come to us
predominantly from Nigeria but also from
other African countries who have been
recruited by nes Cape medical and a
number of other agencies and employers
and put to work either in the NHS or in
private providers
and treated really appallingly and
they've expected to be treated properly
as if they were British workers as you
know as into the standards that we have
here but unfortunately our survey shows
exploitation lack of support threats
particularly to Visa status poor welfare
and low pay
and unsafe hours lack of rest working
above competency or without support are
really threatening patient safety in
those environments so we are looking for
significant changes to their conditions
including Trade union recognition to
apply to all agency medical staff and
for their contracts to improve up to the
standards of the NHS regardless of who
the direct direct employer is
um okay
um some of the figures that are in the
report are really shocking I think 34 of
those surveyed reported bullying and
harassment 47 reporting unfair treatment
and 89 report working over a 70-hour
week not only damaging for the health of
those that are doing those but
potentially for those that they're
caring for absolutely it's frankly
unsafe the conditions that people are
working in and I think that many
particularly those who are paying for
their health care and privates in the
private sector would be shocked and
surprised by the conditions under which
their medical team are working
and there are plenty of doctors under
this survey who told us that they were
working a whole week on 168 hours with
minimal rest breaks during the night
which might be disturbed
and so so 70 hours is really almost at
the low end for many of these people and
and the bullying is I mean quite
horrific I won't repeat some of the
racist things that people have reported
to us and but I was surprised that they
would they would come to such
such harassment in the UK
so who's bullying whom
so it's a mixture so the doctors who are
working for these companies are often
from Nigeria or other similar Nations
and they're facing bullying both from
their employer the agency but also from
their colleagues who are working
alongside them in the health system and
and it's quite difficult to challenge
that because if they challenge that the
agency or their employer is both their
employer their GMC responsible officer
their visa status holder that sometimes
they're landlord so raising concerns
often lead to a position of being very
trapped and it's quite difficult for
people to get out of those situations
um
one wonders who those people can turn to
absolutely and I mean we're we're
encouraging those people to turn to us
as their Trade union we're here to help
we have a contract checking service
we're trying to eliminate really
duplicitous contracts that don't stand
up to a moment scrutiny we're offering
to support to International Medical
graduates who are new to the country
we're lobbying their employers for
improvements to paying conditions
and we're hoping that we can tackle some
of the problems with them at work and
for a range of these organizations which
really shouldn't be allowed to get away
with this any longer